[Music]
my name is
tricked you there didn't i that's the
power of deep
fakes i'm sure you've seen this already
i've seen a couple already but i wanted
to make a video where i react
to the greatest the finest pewdiepie
deep fakes
these things make me cringe like nothing
else this is the
i guess we're bringing back cringe
tuesdays on whatever day of the week it
is
because boy oh boy is this epic okay
this one is made by
next face
pewdie pewdie like then
i've seen this and it's so uneasy to
watch
stop
[Music]
alternate universe where disney didn't
reject me aster troublesome child
oh my god it could have been edgar it
would have been epic why didn't they
deep fake edgar
[Music]
hey congratulations it's so good with
the music
stop thief your sultan commands it
sultan does that mean i'm in trouble
oh it's marcia oh my god
this is so weird
[Applause]
i love the music it's so good
thank you will smith thank you so much
come on
[Applause]
[Music]
what a wholesome ending at the start of
a video
[Music]
and i plan to ask rose
i want to look young for her can i have
a kiss
no i don't know i forgot about jack
oh god really yeah really
so you think i'm bad i'm just i'm a bad
person okay
yeah it looks so bad with jack
i can't watch this i've seen it already
that's
oh my god this is pain
this is burrito glasses again that's son
of a [ __ ] arigato he's gotten better
yes
we learned a lot of jesus this is not as
polish on jack thankfully
things from our japan it's still a curse
it's still cursed how
oh no how much of the time do you feel
happy
with the person rarely oh my god
we just explain each other's point of
views
i can't watch this i can't i'm sorry i
can't
i just can't let's watch some cool ones
this is from
magic of barca captain pewdiepie the
first youtuber
oh god feet marcia
is that me holy sh
i don't think i've seen this
whoa
it's marzia
[Music]
glasses
is the floor gang machine 20 i mean 120
muscle increase take off your shirt your
tie in your head
this is uh we're trying to develop this
so you guys anyone that subscribe get to
use it oh my god
it's weird because me and chris evan
kind of looks similar not that much
but still a little bit big
oh my god stop
hey did you dirty man did you dirty man
[Music]
oh my god marx yeah that's so crazy
i never actually watched captain uh
all right let's see those muscle
increase twenty percent
that's ten percent wait what do you say
that's ten percent twenty oh ten percent
twenty percent
must hit tambourines
[Music]
i can do this
hey
after floor gang everyone hell yeah
[Music]
all juiced up baby how do you feel
i feel like i'm not asleep anymore oh
god oh god no
don't horse ride don't don't oh god if
this isn't cursed i don't know what
is jesus christ get a couple eggs shoot
the chicken with a hundred arrows
tickets really just something
oh
i don't want to see this felix need to
see this i don't
i don't wanna i can't believe this one
marcia sneeze every night
no no god damn
i don't know how much more i can endure
[Music]
the hell is this i'm a bollywood actress
alt universe t-series wins oh god they
did never mind oh god
i mean i do look good though not gonna
lie this one is okay
this one is okay
damn i got the moves
all right what more nightmares do we
have you've just been so shocked that
they're a fan
armstrong my face is so big
day yeah billy jordan i'm strong
justin bieber who you are so cursed with
billy elliott
we were at coachella yep we're watching
ariana grande
oh my god tell me about what he means to
you and why this is such a moment
well if i can be honest with you for
like like
wait all right this is the best one i
think this is the best one i've ever
seen
and it's objective stylish just because
it looks so cursed
like jack must have the exact same bone
structure as billy
bailey alien yeah
[Music]
thank you i'm gonna have you two come on
right over here
my name is dakota i love billy alice so
much she doesn't like cover up the truth
her personality she's very good you
cover up the troops she's so real
you really have friends for a really
long time i would cry a lot i felt
really bad about myself for a really
long time
but then like literally the cure to any
bad moment
i would just play billy eilish
[Music]
i oh it so much
jack is so good with his fans i wouldn't
even take selfies with the
oh classic forgot about this we have a i
did not remember
it's not true it's [ __ ] i did not
hit her i did not
oh hi mark oh hey johnny what's up i
have a problem is that dr phil
she said that i hit her what well did
you
no it's not true don't even ask what's
new with you
well i'm just sitting up here thinking
oh god i got a question for you
yeah you think girls like to cheat oh my
god
what makes you dr philman is awful i
don't know i'm just
i'm just thinking i don't have to worry
about that because lisa is loyal to me
no i can't watch dr phil you're very
stressed out
when will the nightmares end no please
oh
no everybody is that oh it's me playing
pokemon stadium oh set it up for us
because we haven't played anymore
this game gets very intense yeah should
we like
have rules make it more difficult for
each other like
how about i freeze it's so tiny
no no no forget about it
what the hell rule is that
he's playing with six nine excuse me
what the frick
did pierce react to this well i did now
all right the most searched one is
mcgregor but it doesn't show up
yeah i guess because me and mcgregor
look similar oh no what is this
[Music]
okay well on that oh god
thank you for the nightmares thank you i
appreciate it
never do that again thank you for
watching this video
smash like and subscribe for more and
i'll see you guys in the next one
oh god make it stop oh yeah
check out simp merch it's out now
represent.com pewdiepie
ah children of nine parts
it's time to raise what was once
forgotten
what creatures fart spells and poop
troops awaits
poopty is coming to
nintendo switch
and remember it has a very big pp
pre-order promotion i mean